Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by ink
tell and I've used them personally ever
since I wrote the four hour workweek.
I've been asked over and over again
how I choose to delegate tasks,
how I do 80 20 analysis and so on.
At the root of many of those
decisions is a simple question.
Actually two questions.
Number one,
how can I invest money to
improve my quality of life?
I use that in investing as well.
The second,
how can I spend a little money or moderate
money to save significant time inc
tell is one of those investments.
There are a turnkey solution for all
of your imaginable customer care needs.
I used Intel during the launch of
the four hour body, which was very,
very involved and they provided 24
seven customer service for my land rush
campaign because it was critical for
me to take care of every person who
purchased my books and participated.
This allowed me to focus on the things
that I am better. At my strengths,
like the marketing plan that
we'd worked on for six months,
implementing that until
trains their experience.
Customer service reps to
know your business and your
products inside and out and
make your customers are raving fans.
They answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they
can do so across all platforms, including
email, phone, social media, texts,
even chat,
leaving your customers with poor
service or just mediocre service,
which by the way,
in a competitive pool is a huge liability.
Long wait times are unanswered messages
carries a massive cost and risk to your
business.
Intel removes the logistics and
headaches of this type of communication,
allowing you to focus on your
strengths and grow your business.
It can be a real competitive advantage.
And I see many,
many ecommerce companies
and tech companies thinking
of customer service as a
good enough checkbox or an afterthought,
and it just like airbnb use design and
innovative ways to be a competitor and to
win. You can do the same
thing with customer service.
So as a listener of this podcast,
you can get up to $10,000 off.
That's a big discount.
$10,000 off your startup fees and costs
by visiting [inaudible] dot com forward
slash Tim so check it out.
For more info,
go to intel.com I N K t e
l.com forward slash. Tim,
this episode is brought to
you by helix sleep. Last year.
I focused on dramatically improving
a few things. Surprise, surprise,
most notably the quality of my sleep,
which seems to affect just
about everything. This led
me to revisit, you name it,
my daily routine, morning
routine, exercise, diet,
all the way to what I slept on and I
ended up getting all new beds here in
Austin, Texas, including
mattresses from Helix sleep.
He looks as built a sleep quiz that takes
two minutes to complete and they use
the answers to match your body.
Type in sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress, whether you're a side sleeper,
hot sleeper, cold sleeper. Are you
like plus you like firm with Helix,
there's no more guessing or confusion.
Just go to helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim,
take their two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life.
That is their promise for couples.
He looks can even split the
mattress down the middle,
providing individual support needs
and feel preferences for each side.
They have a 10 year warranty and you can
test drive your mattress for 100 nights.
Risk free.
Right now he looks as offering up to $125
off of all mattress orders to check it
out.
Get up to 125 off at Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim that's helix
sleep.com forward slash 10 for $125 off
your mattress order. Take a look.
He looks asleep.com forward slash
Tim
well hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to interview world class
performers, to tease out the habits,
routines, thinking frameworks,
life lessons, favorite books,
etc. That you can apply
and test for yourself.
This episode features someone who is very,
very well known in the world of investing,
but studying what he says is really
a study in clearer thinking and it
transcends investing in business
and so many different ways.
Howard s marks is Cochairman and
cofounder of Oak tree capital management,
a leading investment manager with
more than a $120 billion in assets.
He is the author of the new book,
mastering the market cycle, subtitle,
getting the odds on your side and
his previous book on investing.
The most important thing to uncommon
sense for the thoughtful investor with a
critically acclaimed bestseller.
To give you an idea of who
reads his memos and his writing.
Warren Buffet has written of Howard quote.
When I see memos from Howard
marks in my mail there,
the first thing I opened and read,
I always learned something and quote,
I'm going to keep this short
because it covers a lot of ground.
We talk about the three stages
of a bull market newsletters.
He reads thoughts on Bitcoin and Crypto.
His thoughts on understanding market
cycles for making better decisions.
How his firm was poised to capitalize
on the bubble in 2008 and put massive
amounts of capital to work and
more and more and more and more.
We really cover a lot of ground and I
had a lot of fun. So without further ado,
maybe I've already said that.
Here is Howard marks.
Howard, welcome to the
show. Thank you Jim.
I've been looking forward to being here.
I am thrilled to be sitting here with
you because I have so many fans of your
work and thinking in my friends
circles.
Well that's great to hear.
When I went out to a handful to ask
for potential topics or questions,
there were very,
very forthcoming.
But what I thought I would do
in this particular episode,
I've never done in a podcast episode
before, which is to start with a poem.
This is always risky,
risky business.
But this was suggested
by a friend and he said,
I would use an ae houseman poem.
This capture is effectively the, uh,
I think that what he views as, as, as
the spirit of, of much of your writing
and you can agree or disagree.
Here we go.
Eye To my perils of cheat and
Scharmer come clad in armor by stars.
Benign hope lies to mortals
and most believe her,
but man's deceiver was never mine.
The thoughts of others were
light and fleeting of lovers
meeting or luck or fame.
Mine were, have trouble
in mind. We're steady.
So I was ready when trouble came
and that is a Shropshire lad,
the name of the poem.
And I thought that, uh,
we could certainly talk
about that specifically,
but in the course of doing
research for this conversation,
I discovered that you had studied not
only finance and what you might look at as
vocational subjects when
you were an Undergrad,
but also it seems like Japanese. And, uh,
there was this concept of Mucho that
popped up when I was doing my reading.
Would you mind describing
that time and that concept?
Well, I went to Wharton, um, at a, uh,
at a edit enlightened time when you were
required to have a non business minor
and then a semester of the literature
of a foreign country in English.
I never learned Japanese, but I
started off for some reason, which I,
it's interesting that I
have no recollection of what
motivated me, but I decided,
not French literature or English,
but Japanese literature.
It must've been the exoticism.
Uh,
and I liked it so much that I turned
Japanese studies into my minor and took 15
credits at the graduate level.
And that's what turned me from a,
from an indifferent teenager
into a, into a student. Really.
Um, but the professor,
for most of those courses,
a guy named Dale Saunders was an
inspirational speaker and a Oxford don an
aesthete.
And so I took this course in a Japanese
philosophy and we came across Mucho.
Mucho literally means the turning of
the wheel of the law. In other words,
the operation of life. And, uh, the, the,
the essence is impermanence.
And because La Wheel does turn and,
um,
and also the,
the unpredictability of the future.
And these were really formative for me
and they have an unconsciously informed
everything I've done. Um, and uh,
I think that personally that in the
investment business and also in life,
you are better off if
you realize number one,
that if life is always going to change
on you and there will always be new
things coming down the pike
and you can't control it. Um,
and what we have to do is live with it.
In the course of the reading.
I've done prep for this,
which is not only the, uh, the new
book, but also many of your letters,
which I had already been a fan
of, but went back to revisit. Uh,
I came and grant across many people who
had tried to select favorite quotes and
one that came up a lot.
So you could certainly correct
this if this is not accurate,
is something along the lines of you can't,
you can't predict,
you can prepare.
And that leads me to
and we're going to bounce
around chronologically quite
a lot I suspect. But, uh,
during the 2008 bubble,
which of course it was a time
in which many investors were
pulling out of the market.
Oak Tree did exactly the opposite and you
put more than a half a billion dollars
a week to work over 15 weeks.
Why did you do that? Where are
you predicting where you prepared?
What led to that type of
decision? Sure. Well,
you mentioned the memos.
I've been riding the Malmo
since 1990. Um, and, um,
I wrote one about 20 years
ago, late nineties, uh, cold.
You can't predict.
You can prepare.
I stole the tagline from then an ad
from Northwestern mutual life insurance.
Uh, but I think that's true of life. Uh,
now it sounds like an oxymoron because
how can you prepare if you can't predict?
But the answer is, uh, we never
know what's going to happen,
but we can consider the likely
scenarios and prepare for some of them.
Uh, you can't, I definition prepare
for every eventuality, but, um,
I would say that we did have a sense,
uh,
my partner Bruce Karsh and I,
had a sense in o five and six that
the world wasn't running right.
Um,
and the main thing that made us conclude
that was the crappy deals that were
getting done.
And he and I would spend the day
walking into each other's office saying,
look at this piece of crap that got
issued yesterday. There's something wrong.
A deal like this should not be doable.
The fact that investors are buying
this tells me that they're not being
skeptical. They're not being demanding,
they're not applying standards.
And, um, you know, uh, buffet,
uh, has a, has a saying,
the less prudence with which
others conduct their affairs,
the greater the prudence with which
we must conduct our own affairs.
And it's absolutely true.
Um,
and so we knew that the
market was dangerous because
of the behavior of others.
Now you can't. So we were prepared.
We, we sold a lot of assets.
We liquidated large funds,
we replaced them with small funds.
We became very selective in
our buying. We raised, uh,
a very large fund for investment if a
crisis bursting would come into being,
was this for a distressed
debt for distressed debt.
Now the interesting thing though,
so you can't prepare,
you can't predict.
The thing that caused the bubble to burst,
uh,
was the
unsubstantiated polity of mortgage back
securities. And especially subprime,
if you read the memos, you won't find a
word about it. We didn't predict that.
We didn't even know about it.
It was occurring in an an,
an extra odd corner of the securities
market. Most of us didn't know about it.
Um, but it is what, what brought
the house down and we had no idea,
but we were prepared because
we knew simply that we were
on dangerous ground and
that required a cautious preparation.
Let me ask, and I may embarrass
myself with questions that,
uh, display my ignorance about
many topics in this interview.
But when you raised money
for a distressed debt fund,
did you emphasize to the lps or
whoever gave you those funds that,
uh, you had a specific timeline
in mind for deploying those funds?
Or did you emphasize the importance of
patients with those people and that you'd
be looking for indicators and that
they needed to look at it as a longterm
investment?
How did you manage the question of,
of when from those people?
The question of when is is one of
the hardest ones in our business?
And I always say that we may have
an idea of what's going to happen,
but we never know when
it's going to happen.
You can't call these things as one of
my partners says, if you name a price,
don't name a date.
And if he named the date,
don't name a price and then
you can't be wrong. But, uh,
we never did name it. Date. We
probably, I can't even remember.
We probably had a limit. In other words,
if we hadn't deployed within x years,
then it got cancelled,
the commitments. Um,
but I think there was an understanding
that we thought it was coming within the
next one to three years.
Something like that.
The, the subtitle of this new book, of
course, the title, mastering mark sites,
subtitle,
getting the odds on your side.
Why this book and in the how does one,
and this is of course something we
could, we could discuss, uh, for many,
many hours on end,
but to why this book and how does someone
in this context get the odds on their
side.
So I started writing the memos in
1990 I wrote them for 20 years.
I always concluded that I would write
a book and pull them together into a
philosophy when I retired.
Uh,
and then I got a letter from
Warren Buffet in 2010 is saying,
if you'll write a book,
I'll give you a blurb for the jacket.
So that was enough to get me off my
ass and get me to do it in real time.
Um,
I wrote a book called the most important
thing because I found myself sitting in
client's offices saying the most
important thing is buying cheap.
And then 10 minutes later,
I would say the most important
thing is not losing money.
And then 10 minutes later,
I would say that the most important
thing is contrarion behavior.
So I wrote a book called the most
important thing, which has 21 chapters.
And each one starts off.
The title is the most important thing is,
and then it's a different thing.
One of those most important things is
knowing where we stand in the cycle.
Um, and uh, as I say, I
don't believe in forecasts.
I always say we never
know where we're going,
but we sure as hell ought to
know where we are. I mean,
I can't tell you what's
going to happen tomorrow,
but I should be able to assess the
current environment and that's the kind of
thinking, uh, that helped us
prepare for the, for the crisis. Um,
I think that the two most important
things are where we stand in the cycle and
the broad subject of risk and in fact
where we stand in the cycle is the primary
determinant of risk. Um, so, uh,
I think that this is really an important
topic and it can really help you do
better getting the odds on your side.
What that means is we don't
know what's going to happen.
Nobody can tell you,
but there are times when the future is
the outlook is better and there are times
when it's worse and it's largely
determined by where we stand in the cycle.
When we are low in the cycle,
that is to say we're coming off a bust.
The economy is starting to warm up.
Investors are just barely starting
to switch from pessimism to optimism
and prices are starting to rise.
Clearly the odds are in your favor,
the outlook is better. It doesn't
mean you're going to make money,
but the chances are good. On the other
hand, when the cycle has gone on,
the up cycle has gone on for a long time
when, uh, when, when valuations are high,
when optimism is rampant,
when everybody thinks that
everything's gonna get better forever.
When the economy's been moving ahead for
10 years and it looks like it's never
going to stop,
then usually the enthusiasm has just
carried the prices to such a high level
that the odds are against you.
And just knowing that is as a
huge advantage in investing.
You should know that when the,
when we're low in the up cycle,
that's a time to be aggressive and put
a lot of money to work and buy more
aggressive things.
And when we,
when the cycle has gone on for
a long time and were elevated,
that's the time to take some money off
the table and behave more cautiously.
Question about 2008, uh, or you
could pick another period, uh,
a bus cycle that you're familiar with a
weather from firsthand experience were
from research that you've done.
You raise these funds and I want to
revisit the question of when and from
personal standpoint. Uh, and
I'll admit, admit it very freely.
I think I've had a very fear based
mentality when it comes to public markets.
I've done reasonably well in privately
held technology startups because I've
lived in the middle of the switchbox in
San Francisco and that's the only thing
I paid attention to.
And it protected me and away from my
lesser behaviors because I wasn't allowed
to sell. Uh, but in the public markets,
I've almost always held on to cash,
waiting for some cataclysmic event,
but then lost my nerve in some fashion.
Uh,
I'd be,
I'd love to hear and maybe the catching
falling knives as a way to segue into
this. I don't know, that found that
very, very interesting to read about. Uh,
but how'd you think about sitting on a
position like that and timing of what,
what, what determines the
go command for deploying?
You have really,
okay.
Touched on an extremely important topic.
Okay.
Most of us have an inherent bias.
Most of us are essentially
cautious or essentially aggressive.
Probably more people are essentially
cautious then aggressive.
So one of the most important
things is to assess ourselves,
understand our biases and
try to overcome them. Now,
the Tim Ferriss that I heard you describe,
I take that to mean that maybe you were
lucky or smart enough to turn cautious
leading up to the bubble.
The markets fell apart.
You're sitting on cash,
you patted yourself on the back for
being so smart as to not get caught.
And you're watched what you didn't do
as you didn't turn aggressive at the
bottom. That's right. And it's common, uh,
not to do. So. It's common to,
as you say, for people to say,
I'm not going to jump in while
this things collapsing down.
I'm going to wait till the dust has
settled and the future is clear.
I'm not going to try to
catch a falling knife.
But it is when the knives are falling
that the people are most terrified that
they best bargains are available.
So if you wait until the dust settles,
the bargains are gone. And that's
what happened at the end of, of a,
you mentioned that we in distressed debt,
we put 500 million a week to work in the
last 15 weeks following the bankruptcy
of Lehman brothers and across the firm,
uh,
something like 650 million a week
for 15 weeks. That's $10 billion.
And, but the key is it was at a time
when essentially nobody else would.
You get great bargains.
By the time the end of
Oh eight rolled around,
the hedge funds that were getting
withdrawals had either satisfied their
withdrawals or gated
and what is gated mean,
uh, told clients they couldn't have
their money back for awhile. Gotcha. Um,
and uh, so the, the selling debated,
a few people saw that, that, uh,
the great values and with this,
with the selling,
and thus the fear having reduced,
they were able to come forward, prices
started to move up, then it's too late.
Because if you're trying
to buy in a falling market,
you can buy all you want at
successively lower prices.
But if you're trying to buy
large amounts in a rising market,
your own buying puts the price up.
You're your own worst enemy.
You can't get much at
low prices. So, you know,
one of the keys to successful investing
is to either be unemotional or at
minimum act like you are. Uh, you know,
the great investors I know are
behave in an unemotional fashion.
You know, Warren Buffet
couldn't care less. Uh,
David Tepper couldn't care less
and, and, uh, and so forth. Um,
uh, my own partner, Bruce Karsh,
very, very, very stalwart.
But part of it is that we support each
other at the bottom. It's not easy,
you know, and, and a,
I say in the book that I recount some of
the things we've done right with regard
to cycled extremes,
but I absolutely don't want to
give the impression that it's easy.
It's terrifying. Others are
terrified. That's why they're selling.
That's why they're saying, I don't care
what the price is, just get me out.
That's what,
that's when you want to buy.
But the things that terrify them
into selling, we'll also terrify you.
You have to overcome it.
How much of that stoic resilience
or a stoic composure is a
nature versus nurture
born versus trained in,
in from what you've observed
and experienced. And, and if,
if a portion of it is trained,
how,
how would you suggest to someone
that they develop that ability?
I don't want to answer categorically.
I think it's a hell of a lot easier.
If you're born then you know, to, to,
to teach yourself to be unemotional is to,
is to count their human nature. And
by definition, it can't be easy.
Um,
this is other than as to,
you know,
uh,
where are we in the cycle and what's
going to happen in the SEC coming six
months? This is probably the
question I get the most often. Hmm.
How can you teach herself to be
unemotional, to be contrarian,
to be a second level thinker?
Um, and there is no easy answer,
uh, in, in the first book on the subject
of what I call second level thinking.
I say, uh, in basketball they
say you can't coach height.
All the coaching in the world will
not yet make your team taller.
So I don't know, frankly, whether you can,
whether people can teach
themselves to be unemotional,
but clearly if you are
as emotional as others,
you will probably succumb
to the same errors.
So let's, I think we can not, I'd
love to back into this type of, uh,
not psychological profiling,
but an examination of,
of this type of resilience.
Maybe indirectly. Maybe it'll
come up, maybe it won't,
but, and I might get
the total duration, uh,
incorrect. But you mentioned the
name Bruce Karsh that I'd love to,
to bring up yet again. And he made me make
him up repeatedly. 23 year partnership,
is that right? Or 20 plus year. 31 and
31. Okay. Oaktree is 23 years. I got,
we worked together for eight years
before the prior to that. All right, so
if you were trying to hire a say
25 year old version of Bruce,
what would you be looking for?
Well, I'll tell you what he
is, let's, let's do that. He's
super smart. That goes
without saying. He is
highly competitive. Uh, you know,
he, he's a chess player and, and,
and most of the people that are, again,
that I know who are good investors are,
are, are a games players,
either backgammon or, or,
or chess or something like that.
Um,
we are an inherently competitive, um, uh,
he's also a very analytical
and he's kind of a grinder.
And I would describe myself
as being intuitive and,
and a quick decider thinking
slow and fast. Conaman um,
I'm a fast thinker.
You tell me a problem.
I tell you my answer in short order
and I'm done with it for the most part,
Bruce,
we'll think about it longer,
come to his conclusion and then it'll
come back the next day. And he said,
you know,
I was thinking about it last night.
I don't think that's right and here's why.
Or I don't think you were right
and here's why. And he'll,
he'll grind on it for hours and days.
I think this is part of the
secret to our success. Uh,
again, something I once wrote a on the
subject of a good partnership, I should,
I said shared values and
compliment the re skills.
If you have a partner who has
different values than you do,
for example,
uh,
w Bob wants to make the most money
possible and Ed wants to operate with
integrity.
Those are largely contradictory.
So I think it's very important to
share values, but I also think it's,
it's important to not be the same
person, a copy of yourself. If you're,
if it's a copy of yourself,
you don't need it, it,
it the person should bring skills that
you don't bring and maybe operate in ways
you don't.
And I think it's,
it's probably helpful that I'm
intuitive and he's analytical.
I've heard, well heard, that's not the
right not the right verb. I've read, uh,
I believe is Buffett who said
that Charlie Munger has the,
something along the lines of the
best 62nd mind he's ever encountered.
It sounds like you also have a very
highly developed fast thinking capacity.
Is how is it similar or different
from Charlie mungers 62nd?
Well, it, if, first of all,
it's a daunting comparison.
I would never put myself in the
category with Charlie. He's, he's,
he's brilliant than, and a one of
the best thinkers there is. But, uh,
you know, uh, I mean,
the main thing is that he has
read more broadly. He's had,
he's had another 22 years to read further.
And knee was probably always,
uh, a broader reader
than I was. And so it's,
it's his ability to call on
these references, you know, uh,
in a way it's kind of silly to think we
have to end or that we can reinvent all
the wisdom in the world. It's great
to borrow from others and, and,
and Charlie does that broadly and
I try to do it. He just knows more.
I think we'll,
we'll
almost certainly come back to a more an
in Charlie Moore in this conversation,
but I want to return to to Bruce because
you mentioned the complimentary skill
sets and you've,
you've written about him of course,
quite a bit and mentioned him
quite a bit and I want to pull up
quickly just a few lines.
In the new book,
it's Bruce and I have exchanged ideas and
backed each other up almost daily over
that period. This is a proceeding
taxed and my give and take with him,
especially in the most difficult of times
has played particularly indispensable
part and the development of the approaches
to cycles on which this book spaced.
Could you share an example of a,
of back and forth or disagreement during
a difficult time or with a particular
decision? Uh, does that possible
just so that we can we have a,
a real world example of,
of the interplay between the two of you?
We,
we normally don't debate
individual investments because
he operates more at that
level. And I operate more at the
big picture level within oak tree.
But I mean, I think a good
example is in the period we just,
we've been talking about
a couple of times now,
we've mentioned the last 15
weeks of Oh eight. Um, you know,
it was really a very tough period because
a Lehman brothers had gone bankrupt
and, uh, and uh,
bear Stearns had disappeared and Merrill
Lynch had been absorbed by Bank of
America and Washington mutual and
Wacovia Bank. And, uh, you know, and it,
it looked like falling dominoes and it,
you know,
people were talking about the fact that
Morgan Stanley was next and Goldman was
right behind that.
And so you just had to
conclude that the world,
that the financial world was
either going to end or it wasn't,
you couldn't analyze it. You could improve
anything about the future. And, and, and,
and so it required a,
an almost gamesman like approach
to whether you buy or not.
And, uh, you know, we would
talk about that in that sense.
And we were both very comfortable
talking about it in that sense.
And what we concluded was that
if the world ended,
it didn't matter what we did,
but if the world didn't end and we
hadn't bought, we hadn't done our job.
So buck up and do your job.
Now, the great thing is that half
the days Bruce would come to me,
cause he would be lying in bed at night
thinking about this stuff and he would
come to me and he would say, you know
what? I think we're going too fast.
I think we should slow down.
And half the days he would say,
I think we're going too
slow. And, uh, you know,
so I would play devil's
advocate, um, and uh,
and support his decision. But, but
try to show him the other side.
And he would do that with me. And
that's why we got it done. But I,
as I say in the, in the introduction
to the book, from what you read,
I think that I don't think either of
us could have done as good a job alone.
I think that the devil's advocacy and,
but in a supportive way,
uh, really held the key. Um,
I wrote in one of my memos,
I wrote about a reporter,
uh,
and he,
he called me up a few days after the
bankruptcy of Lehman and he said,
what are you doing? I said, we're
buying. He said, you are like,
it was the craziest thing he ever
heard. And you know, my reaction was,
if we're not buying now and we
will, um, but, uh, you know,
it's been a great partnership.
As you say, 31 years.
Never an argument. Never an
argue, never an argument.
I mean intellectual disagreements,
but never an emotional argument and never,
and the key
is respect.
Even when we disagree.
We respect.
And the great thing about that
is you sit down, you disagree.
You,
maybe you don't come to the enclosure
and then you go back to your corners and
he says, well, you know what,
maybe how it's right. And I say,
maybe Bruce is right and then you can
have a productive discussion. If, if you,
if your reaction is that moron,
then you can't benefit
from what he has to say
for,
for people who were hoping to exhibit
that type of poise and respect for someone
else, are there any tactical
recommendations you might have?
And the reason I asked that is, uh,
I no longer live in silicon valley,
but I was there for 17 years and you
see cofounder splits all the time.
Some of them go the distance,
but a lot of them end up fatalities.
And you can almost see the writing on the
wall when they're specked goes out the
window. And it's just a matter of
time for a lot of these guys, uh, for,
for people who are in partnership,
let's just for the time being,
assume it's in a business
capacity or an investing capacity,
what are some of the tools of the
trades that it doesn't escalate?
Do you walk out of the room if
you're starting to get heated there?
Or do you avoid in some systems
way given policies of the firm?
Any types of sort of mission critical
single decisions from becoming an object
of argument, if that makes any sense.
Because when the stakes are high,
what are some, some recommendations
you would have when things,
when perhaps emotions
are starting to escalate?
Well, the only issue I would
take, Tim, is you started with,
assume you're in partnership. I
think you have to start sooner. Okay.
Who Do you get in partnership with?
And you know,
you have to,
you have to share values and you shouldn't
be partners with somebody you're not
going to like enjoy spending time with
and be able to work with constructively
when the stuff hits the fan.
That's really the case. So, I mean,
I believe that that most solving
most personnel or managerial,
uh,
problems start at the beginning with
the hiring decision or the combination
decisions. So, so, uh, you know,
just don't get into business with somebody
you're not going to be able to live
with. It's kind of like a marriage. Uh,
do you stress test their ability to
handle potential high stress situations in
some real or simulated fashion?
Do you look back at in say,
hiring decision?
Do you look back at their history
and reference checks to assess that?
How do you assess whether someone
is going to keep their cool or not?
Well, we don't do simulations or war
games or anything like that, but we do,
you know, I mean, that's an important part
of reference checking. Uh, you have to,
you have to look beyond whether the
person is smart and whether the person's a
moneymaker, you know, uh, uh,
we have a no assholes rule at oak tree
and I think that saves solves a of
problems. Then, you know,
there are lots of people in the world
who can make you a lot of money, but you,
you may not want to be in
business with them and it,
it may not be viable long term.
Now it's,
it's hard to absolutely follow that rule,
uh,
because really smart moneymakers
are very tempting. But I think it's,
I think it's really important,
but, but then, you know, once,
once you are in business together and
you have the inevitable disagreement,
I think one of the most important
things is to, number one,
acknowledge the limits on
what, you know, if you,
if you go in with some humility,
then you're unlikely to have a fight to
the death that is to the death of your
partnership over an issue.
And, and it's, it's, you know,
it's great to say,
I mean,
people should wake up in the morning
and start the day by practicing.
I don't know. I don't know.
It's a great thing to say.
And not enough people say it. And,
and the, the, the, the flip side of,
I don't know, is what I said
before about our discussions. The,
maybe he's right.
You know,
and so I think that's
important. Humility. Number two,
again,
a control of emotion.
Don't get into fight just to
show who's who's more manly, uh,
or you know, or, or equate, uh,
winning the argument with success.
Because if you're,
if you're in a business situation and
you're fighting for something that
ultimately proves out to be a mistake,
your success in winning the
argument will lead to a failure.
Um, so don't confuse winning the argument
with coming to the best decision. Um,
and you know, again, try
to limit the testosterone.
Um,
I think that really gets in the way.
One,
uh,
one of the many things that I really
enjoy about your writing is that it serves
for me at least as a reflection on clear
thinking that transcends investing.
It'll, it applies to so many
if not all areas of life,
at least those governed by
anything in the prefrontal cortex.
And one that caught my eye when I was,
when I was reading just page 15
in the new book is the following.
And, uh, I'd just like to
read, it's not very long.
In addition to an opinion
regarding what's going to happen,
people should have a view on the
likelihood that their opinion will prove
correct. Some events can be predicted
with substantial confidence. Example,
given we'll a given investment grade bond,
pay the interest in promises.
Some are uncertain example,
will Amazon still be the leader in online
retailing and 10 years and some are
entirely unpredictable example. Will the
stock market go up or down next month?
It's my point here that not
all predictions be treated
as equally likely to be
correct in us.
They shouldn't be relied on equally.
I don't think most people are as
aware of this as they should be.
Could you expand on this a bit,
if that's possible,
maybe give some examples of how you or
other people you respect use that type
of,
of puristic when making decisions or just
I suppose reflecting reality in their
own minds are perceiving
things. Sure. You know,
okay,
we all have opinions and we hold our
opinions because we believe in them.
Nobody ever says,
you know,
my opinion is x and I think I'm wrong.
We all think that our
opinions are correct. Uh, but,
and, and, and again, the
world becomes a better place,
an easier place to navigate if we admit
that even though there are opinions that
they may be wrong. Uh,
and, uh, you know, how,
how does an investor like me deal with
the fact that he doesn't believe in
future predictions and, and,
uh, and the answer is a,
I say,
and I have opinions on all these subjects,
but I say it's one thing to
have an opinion and there's it,
it's another to believe
and act as if it's right.
And if you just say,
maybe I'm wrong.
If the world gets easier, in my opinion,
uh, easier to succeed, uh, less,
less easy to, to, to navigate
day to day. You know, and,
and a big theme of the book is
that we have to view the future,
not as an event which is
predetermined and predictable or,
you know, determined already,
but as a range of possibilities,
as a probability distribution.
And you know,
I went to the world's fair in
flushing in 1964 I think it was.
And I stood before an exhibit
that IBM had and it was, you know,
typical of technology 50 odd years ago.
It was the most simplistic thing
you could imagine. They had,
they had a slot at the top and a bunch
of balls and the balls came through the
slot. And then there were
a bunch of pegs in a grid.
And when the ball's hit the pegs,
they started to diffuse.
And by the time they get to the bottom,
they were in a bell shaped distribution.
And I think that was probably my
first exposure to a distribution.
But it's beautiful and that's how life is.
The future is a distribution
of possibilities.
And if we're really smart,
we know what the distribution,
what the possibilities are,
and we may have an idea of which
are more likely and less likely,
but we still don't know what's
going to happen. And, and,
and I think we have to behave that
way now. Some things we know more,
some things we know less, we
shouldn't get confused. But the,
the most important single thing is to
not have the same degree of conviction
about all of our opinions.
Do you apply a biopsy of
one to 10 numerical value?
Is it more of a light,
medium strong had?
How do you think about that yourself?
Yeah, well I think it's
certainly not, you know,
I'm not for the most part a
quantifier if you read the book,
uh, I would hope you would be struck
by how few numbers there are in it.
Um, and uh, you know,
one of the great quotes which has
broadly attributed to Einstein,
I don't think it was Einstein,
is that not everything that can be counted
counts and not everything that counts
can be counted.
So the most important insights
to life or non quantitative.
Um,
but I,
I try to be conscious of when I have
an opinion of how likely it is to be
correct and I try really hard not to
always assume that I'm right. By the way,
let me add one thing. Um, Henry Kaufman,
who was the chief economist of
Solomon Brothers in the 70s, uh,
at a time when America was
riven with hyperinflations 15,
16, 17% a year, nobody could figure
out how to stop it. And, and,
and the world was really a very
difficult place to live at. Kauffman.
There was two guys, Kaufman and
now, well, and our first Boston,
they were called Doctor Gloom.
And Doctor Doom and, and, but,
but Kaufman said two kinds of
people lose a lot of money.
The people who know nothing and the
people who know everything and um,
uh, it's very few of us know nothing,
but it's really important to assume,
to not assume we know everything.
Is there any reading you've done or maybe
it's just real life experience in the
trenches of doing this
day in, day out. But, uh,
if for people who want
to develop that, uh, I,
I saw that you're,
it seems like a reader or a fan of some
of what Nassim Taleb has put out and he
talks about epistemological
arrogance quite a bit.
It's a thinking that we are believing.
We know it all or more than we,
we actually know. How would you suggest,
are there any resources, letters, books,
memos,
talks that you might recommend to
people who want to really cultivate that
awareness of limited knowledge?
Well, when you started to ask that
question, I did fast forward to, uh,
uh, Nassim Nicholas to lab and
his book fooled by randomness.
Uh,
I think it's a really important
book in terms of its ideas and,
uh, it's, uh,
it's really about how much
randomness there is in our world.
Now. It's primarily about
investing, not the general world,
but the world of investing.
And you know,
his example that if you're a dentist,
he picks on the dentist a lot in the book,
but it,
but if you're a dentist on economist,
yes.
And you always fill a tooth the same way
you'll always get a successful filling.
Whereas in the investment business,
there's nothing that you can do that
if you do it the same every time,
you're going to get a successful
outcome because of the changeability and
randomness in the world.
Um, and, and, uh, this is,
uh, extremely important and, uh, you know,
we have to think about the world as
a probability distribution when we,
you know, one of the things that interest
me most is when you look at history,
you say, well, I don't know so much
about the future, but the history that's,
that's done, that's settled. We know what
happened, we know what the truth was.
But to lab uses a concept
called alternative histories.
The other things that reasonably
probably could've happened but didn't.
And so when you look at a
historical event, you have to say,
was it,
was that outcome inevitable,
in which case that demonstrates a a
truth or was it subject to randomness and
could other things have happened just as
well? You know, I wrote a memo, uh, in,
in a memo around Oh six,
I talked about the rose bowl game between
USC and University of Texas and USC
was highly touted as the best team in
the history of foot college football.
And,
and I won't go through all of it,
but I hope readers will take a look at it.
But in the end they lost on one play.
And so nobody talked about them as
being the best football team in history.
My point was, and I wrote, I
entitled this section, What's real?
Maybe they were the best team in history
and maybe the fact that they didn't,
weren't successful on that one play
that the whole game then maybe it was
because the wind was blowing left to
right rather than right to left at that
moment.
And so we should not be too
firm in our conclusions.
I guess the recurrent theme is that is,
is a lack of certainty,
but I really would push people
to fooled by randomness. Uh,
there's a little book by John Kenneth
Galbraith called the short history of
financial euphoria and a great quote, he
said, we have two kinds of forecasters,
the ones who don't know, and the ones
who don't know, they don't know. And,
and that has been very, uh,
inspirational for me. I was, uh,
I don't think this was
attributed to you, but, uh,
I came across it in looking at
some highlights of your memos, uh,
in prep for this conversation.
And I don't think it's attributed to you,
but someone said,
dumb money can become smart money
if it accepts its limitations.
I don't know if he would agree
with that, but it, it, it's,
it stuck with me is maybe
not necessarily forecasters,
but at least people who cultivate
becoming aware of what they don't know.
Sure. Well, I think first of all,
knowing what you don't know is one
of the keys to success in anything.
You know, dirty Harry said a man
should know his limitations. Uh,
I wouldn't say, Eh, it's not my quote.
I wouldn't necessarily say the dumb
money can be smart money. Uh, but, but I,
I would say that one of the ways to avoid
being dumb money is to not act as if
you know things you don't know.
Uh,
maybe by the time I get done
giving the quote, I'll be,
are ever able to remember who said it,
but somebody very wise said Mark Twain.
That's it.
It's not what you don't know
that gets you into trouble.
It's what you know for certain that
just ain't true. That is so important.
There's nothing more dangerous
in life than being sure you know,
something that you don't know if you are,
if you have excess certitude,
you will do things boldly in dangerous
ways and to dangerous extents that have
the ability to get you into trouble,
get you killed.
But a sentence that starts
you off with I'm not sure,
but is unlikely to lead to fatal action.
The distinction to me is so
clear and so unarguable that I,
I think this is one of the most important
things for life. Know your limitations.
You mentioned a little bit earlier how
you could potentially say to yourself in
the morning, I don't know. I don't
know. Maybe he or she is right.
Maybe he or she is. Right. Uh,
and it makes me think of some of these
Memento Mori type quotes that, uh,
maybe maybe apocryphal from ancient Rome
or they'd have someone behind or the
emperor when he's being paraded through
the streets and you're just a man.
You're just a man. Something like that.
I know this is, this is seemingly,
maybe not on the same topic, but
nonetheless, I, I want to ask about it.
Do you have any particular routines or
habits in the first say hour or two of
your day, whether it's now or
whether you are kind of, if you can,
if there were a particularly productive
period in your professional life where
you feel like those routines or
habits in the morning were important?
Does anything come to mind?
I don't have a stylized routines.
I mean,
I would just say that my life is,
uh,
is pretty calm and I try to
keep it that way. Uh, and um,
what would be a symptom of it not being
common? How would you respond to that?
Well,
watching too much political TV and
getting exercised about what you see on TV
would be a good example. I mean,
uh, that's, that's negative energy.
That's not going to contribute to
your effectiveness in the day. Now my,
the fact that I don't get exercised
about what I see on the news shows, uh,
is not purposeful.
So up to this point,
we've talked a fair amount about
the importance of avoiding Hubris,
of understanding your limitations,
the incompleteness of your knowledge.
How do you balance that with perhaps
knowing your strengths well enough or
having conviction in evidence to the
extent that you can then take action?
Sure.
That's a great question,
Tim.
And clearly it's essential to balance.
Uh,
you don't want to be the person
who thinks he knows everything,
but you can't be very successful in
life and especially not in investing.
If you think you're the person who knows
nothing, uh, there is no magic in it.
Uh, there is no rule, no method. Uh,
it's just the, uh, an
awareness. Um, but we,
we have to feel, we know
enough to take action. Now,
most successful people,
most smart people,
uh, have, uh, don't have
a problem in that area.
They have a history of having their
ideas validated for the most part.
Um, but I think it's, it's, it's,
I mean it is one of the great
conundrums which is unanswerable.
Uh, methodologically, you
know, you buy a stock at 80,
it falls to 60. You say, well,
I think it's cheaper now. I like
it more. I'm going to buy more.
You buy more now as well as the 40. Is
there a point at which you say, well,
maybe I'm wrong and maybe the
market's right. Uh, you know,
if you, if you throw in the towel
and sell every stock you buy,
when it goes down a little, you
can, you can never be successful.
But if you ignore the
possibility that you're wrong,
you can ever be successful. Um, and you,
you have to strike a balance. So, uh,
when you buy a stock and
it goes down a little,
you take another look at your analysis.
Is there anything you missed?
Did your analysis hold water and,
and so forth.
Maybe you talk to some people that you
respect, uh, to get their opinions.
Um, but, uh, you know, again, if you're,
if you're too sure you're in trouble and
if you're too unsure, you're in trouble.
Uh,
you have to strike a balance.
If we come back to the,
the hypothetical example,
you gave someone buying at 60 drops to
40 drop to 30 drops to 20 to avoid being
in that position where you are offering
yourself the option of buying or selling
at each of those check in points.
What are you deciding in advance so that
you don't make those interim mistakes
or you don't even make those decisions or,
or look at them to begin with.
That's not my approach or oak trees
approach. We don't have preset rules.
Everybody says,
well,
why didn't you just a rule that there
are things called stop loss orders.
You buy something goes down 20%.
You sell it every time.
There is no rule that will
ever work in every case. Uh,
you have a say. You have a rule
that goes down 20 year out,
so it goes down 21 Esl,
then it goes up a hundred,
you know, or it goes down 10,
you don't sell and it never
goes up again. Uh, there,
there can't be a rule that
always works when they,
just before the publication
of my other book, uh,
I had lunch with Charlie Munger and,
and at the end of the lunch and when I
got up to go, he said, now, just remember,
none of this is meant to be easy.
Anybody who thinks it's easy, as stupid,
these things cannot be reduced to a rule.
The market
operates,
so as to confound rule makers.
Uh, you know, it, it,
and I wrote a memo five years ago called,
it's not easy.
It all comes down to judgment.
We have to have,
if we're going to have superior
investment performance,
we have to have superior
judgement. And, uh, you, you,
I mean, you can work on your processes
both intellectual and emotional,
but you can't, I mean,
superior judgement is,
isn't something you can order up and
not everybody can necessarily attain it.
Um, but, uh, I mean,
I think that one of the
most important things is,
is to dismiss the concept of a process
or a rule that always works in the
absence of superior judgement.
Is the judgment,
the,
the decision to take a certain path
versus another. In other words,
and I know I'm going to be
bastardizing this, but if, if,
if an advantage could take the form
of access to better information,
better analysis of that information,
uh,
making a better decision with the,
with that information that is available,
having the courage to act on it,
and then the emotional fortitude to
either act on it or also sit with that
decision.
And there,
there may be other behavioral
psychological advantages or disadvantages.
I'm sure there are.
When you talk about judgment,
is that a particular link in that,
in that chain?
Is it a,
I think judgment is
everything. Uh, for example,
just to follow your taxonomy,
judgment is knowing when you have
information that others don't.
And if you think,
you know something that others don't,
it's knowing when yours is likely to
be valid and not knowing whether you're
likely to be off beat.
It's understanding how to analyze it.
It's judgment is,
is,
is the reaching of conclusions
based on your analysis. Um,
and a judgment is all we have to tell
us when something goes against us,
whether we should hang
in or give up. So, uh,
as I say,
I think it's all judgment.
I would imagine a lot of people read
your memos and your writing to develop in
hopes of developing better judgment.
And that while there,
there is no one rule that will work
for all circumstances, all cases.
There may be certain questions
or tools that proof helpful in,
uh, in a greater percentage of
cases than others. And to, to that,
I would love to refer to a few
things that I have in front of me.
One is,
is a letter that you sent to me along
with the book and towards the end of the
letter, it's, it, uh, it says,
I draw my 50 years of investing experience
to provide an orientation to the
usual cycles in the economy,
corporate profits,
the availability of credit and the
securities markets as well as some of the
less ordinary ones. For example, in
distress debt, investor psychology,
and even in success.
But I think potentially,
I think potentially the most
useful chapter or the most
useful is the chapter on
the cycle and attitudes towards risk.
How investors are thinking about
risk and behaving toward it.
At a point in time might be the single
most influential determinant of markets
position in the cycle.
Uh,
and thus the best indicator of how we
should behave with regard to, and I,
I read that chapter, I believe I
had the right chapter and there's a,
there's a point in this chapter that is a,
that has a few lines bolded,
which I really appreciate by
the way. And it is, if I could,
if I could ask only one question
regarding each investment I had under
consideration, it would be simple how
much optimism is factored into the price.
Uh,
could you talk about this question and
perhaps give some examples of using it or
how people might use it?
Sure.
You know,
I started in the business in
a summer job at Citi Bank,
summer 68 50 years ago.
And the bank was an investor in the
fifth what was called the nifty 50 the 50
best and fastest growing
companies in America.
And if you bought the stocks the year
I showed up and held him five years,
you've lost almost all of your money
in the best companies in America.
Then 10 years later, I switched to
the, uh, so-called junk bond business,
high yield bonds.
Now I'm lending money to the worst
companies in America and I'm making money
steadily and consistently. So, uh,
clearly buying good things can't be
the secret to success in investing and
avoiding bad things.
It has to be the price you pay.
It's not what you buy, it's
what you pay. And there are,
there's no asset which is so good
that it can't become overpriced.
This is of course,
something that people have to bear in
mind when they look at the Fang stocks.
And on the other hand, those who don't
know could fangs, Facebook, Amazon,
Netflix, Google, and, and
they throw in alphabet too.
Um,
and um,
so there is no asset which is so
good that it can't be overpriced.
There are very few assets which are so
bad that they can't be underpriced and us
a bargain. So what we have to look for if
we're going to be successful investors.
Uh, now my school, which
is called value investing,
puts more emphasis than perhaps a
venture capital or or growth investing,
which largely looks for brilliant futures.
But the key is paying a low price
relatives on to something called intrinsic
value. If you pay a high
price relative to the value,
you're unlikely to do well and yeah,
probably have to get lucky
to have a good return.
But if you pay a low price relative to
the intrinsic value, then the odds, again,
like my book says are,
are on your side.
So we want low price to value.
How do you get low price to value?
And the answer is low optimism.
There are other ways to describe it.
You mean looking for low overall optimism,
right? If, if, if the insured,
the things that everybody feels good
about are likely to be the things that are
high priced and the things that everybody
feels bad about are likely to be low
price. So, uh, if you
could find out that here's,
here's a stock, nobody thinks this
company can ever have a good day,
maybe there's a chance to do,
produce some favorable surprises and
make you a lot of money. If there's a,
if there's a s a company
like the nifty 50 back in 68,
everybody assumed literally,
Tim,
nothing bad could ever
happen to these stocks,
then clearly there has to be so much
optimism and the price that it's,
that there'll never,
there can never be favorable surprise.
We make money from favorable surprises.
And if,
if the conviction of a
positive conviction is so high,
then by definition there can never
be a favorable surprise. So, uh,
I think that this is a number one concept.
You, you, you, you
mentioned, uh, this, I think,
I think you said the word never
in this sort of hypothetical, uh,
exuberant enthusiasm. But someone
might say, and what I believe you,
there's certain words you
dislike using pay, pay,
pay attention to when they come up
of the, uh, of this, uh, lack of,
uh, intellectual Hubris, right?
We should never say,
never.
Always has to,
can't,
you know, these, these,
these expressions are far too absolute
to be winners in a world beset by
uncertainty. And, um, and uh, when you,
when you use those words, uh,
you tend to get into big trouble
when assessing a public sentiment.
And I think it could be really wide.
Let's say anyone participating in
the SB 500, it could be narrower,
but let's, let's assume we're
looking at the, the, the broad,
uh, the broadest collection of market
participants at least, let's just,
let's just say s and p 500.
I was texting with a friend of
mine who's a successful investor,
very different stylistically than
yourself. And I asked him, I said, what,
what would people use are, or what
do you invest in pros use or what's,
what do some of them use to measure
how feel fearful or greedy? Uh,
and then in quotation marks, the market
is, are there, go to indices, are poles.
And he said, people use the vix
as a measure of fear Vix. Uh,
and then,
uh,
he said some people might use something
like yield on junk bonds as a measure.
In other words, low yield equals
complacent market. What are,
let's say, it seems so difficult to
keep track of the media as a whole,
although certainly it becomes obvious at
some point if it's all negative or all
positive. Are there, uh,
particular indicators that you
like to pay attention to or,
or your affirm likes to,
to at least keep an eye on?
In the old book,
there's a chapter that talks about the
importance of taking the temperature of
the market, knowing where
we stand. And it has a, it,
it includes with a checklist,
uh,
largely tongue in cheek,
called the poor man's guide to market
assessment and basically ask them simple
questions. What's going on? Are,
are if a new fund comes out,
does it sell out immediately
or does it struggle? Um, if,
uh, if, uh, if an investor goes to a
cocktail party, yeah, there you are.
It's also a new book. Oh, it's also in
the new model. It's great. It's, you know,
if an, if an investor like me
goes to a cocktail party, is he,
is he the center of attention
that everybody wants to talk to?
Well that's probably a sign
that the interest in the
market is too high or is he
pushed into a corner and everybody wants
to talk to, to the, uh, athletes and the,
and the venture capital guys.
And that's probably an indication that
interested my part of the market is too
low and that bargains may be available.
Uh, you know, and when you turn on TV,
uh, is it all they want to talk about
is the good news or the bad news?
And I have some cartoons
in, in, in the notebook,
uh, old cartoons dredged up
from my files. Uh, but you know,
um, it, it just,
they demonstrate that virtually everything
in the world and in the markets is
subject to a either positive or a
negative interpretation. And if, if,
if everybody is interpreting positively,
that tells me that the,
that the spirits are too high and,
and perhaps ready to be dashed
and, and vice versa. You know,
the greatest thing I was ever taught
was back around 73 74 somebody said,
I'm going to tell you about the
three stages of the bull market.
And in the first stage,
just a few incredibly insightful
people understand that there could be
improvement.
And in the second stage,
most people recognize that
improvement is actually taking place.
And in the third stage,
everybody and his brother believes that
things will only get better forever.
Now I think this is number one, this is
a very accurate description of the world.
Number two,
clearly if you buy in the first stage
when only a few people understand the
potential for improvement,
you're going to pay a low price because
there isn't much optimism in the price.
Then as you progress to
the second and third stage,
the UN anticipated improvement takes
place that gives the market a favorable
surprise.
The stock prices or the asset prices
rise in response to those favorable
surprises. Um, and uh,
but you eventually reach a point where
the good news convinces people that it's
going to go on forever.
And when everybody believes that
things will get better forever,
clearly it's likely that so much
optimism is in the stock price,
that it's dangerous and
unlikely to yield a profit.
So I think that the three stages of the
bull market, uh, and conversely of the,
of the bear market are really important,
not as a money making rule,
but as something to bear
in mind and watch out for.
I'm going to ask you a few questions
that, that, uh, you may not like,
but that my fans will kill
me for if I don't ask.
So where,
uh,
it gets number one is where do
you think we are at the moment?
And of course this has to be
timestamped. Uh, and then we're,
we're talking about in the August,
and what has you worried,
what has you optimistic if you're
optimistic about anything? Sure. Well,
where are we for the last 10 years?
Ever since the crisis,
people have been asking that question in
the form of what inning are we in? Eh,
when they asked it in late oh eight,
what they really meant was, uh,
how much longer will the pain go on?
Uh,
now what they're asking is how much longer
will the pleasure go on and the bull
market and the economic recovery,
I think we're in the eighth inning now.
You don't have to timestamp.
But because I've been saying
this for awhile, um, and,
and I'm likely to continue to do so.
But about a year ago,
I came to realization
that that observation,
even if accurate is of limited use.
Because unlike baseball,
we don't know how many innings there are
in a game. This is a big distinction.
In a normal baseball game,
we know there are nine innings.
If I say we're in the eighth,
and if I say it accurately,
that means the good
times are about to end.
But in economies and markets,
there is no fixed duration.
So the bull market,
this is the 10th year.
That's a long time in
the economic recovery.
This month we have begun the 10th year.
The longest economic recovery
in recent history is 10 years.
So these observations start to tell you,
not that it's gonna end, but that the
likelihood of its continuing is declining.
The odds are not on your side.
When you're in the 10th year,
the odds of having 10 more years
of recovery seemingly are not good.
We don't know if there's some reason why
there has never been a recovery of more
than 10 years. Uh, but we
have to wonder if there is.
Um, but on the other hand,
we can't be too sure. Uh,
now I believe that this economic recovery
for many years was the slowest on
record.
That is probably helpful because that
kept excesses from coming into existence
that have to be corrected, uh,
with a, with a downturn. Um,
so you asked about the good news.
The good news is that the economy
is functioning at a high level.
We just had a quarter of
unusually rapid growth. Um,
unemployment is declining.
Our economy is the envy of
the world. Um, stock prices,
which were very high when measured by
price earnings ratio last year are not so
expensive this year because the earnings
have been supercharged by the tax bill.
The projected earnings of the s and
p 500, uh, our, our way up this year,
23%, I think, which is
unusual and higher earnings.
Everything else being equal means I
lower price earnings ratio. So on Mo,
by most measures,
a stocks are only slightly
expensive at this point in time.
So that's the good news.
The bad news is number one,
interest rates are likely to increase and
interest rates increased the burden of
debt on companies.
And when bonds yield more,
they offer more competition for stocks.
Uh,
clearly there are a lot of uncertainties
in the macro world and the geopolitical
world and the political
world. Um, the, the,
the greatest of which is the
possibility of a trade war, which, uh,
almost everybody thinks would
be extremely negative, uh,
not only for the u s and for the
people who engage in the trade war,
but for everyone. And, uh,
I think that interestingly,
what we've been talking about is assessing
the level of investor psychology.
I don't believe that investor
psychology is terribly frothy.
The way I've put it in the past is
that people are not thinking bullish,
but they're acting bullish.
A lot of people have moved into higher
risk investments in order to get the
returns they want because right now,
safe investments,
treasuries and,
and high grade bonds and cash and
money markets or for so little.
So people have been forced to move out
the risk curve and take more risk and
that makes the world a riskier
place for you and me. Uh, I,
I borrowed a phrase from my late father
in law who said that those people could
be described as handcuffed volunteers.
They're doing things not because they
want to, but because they have to.
But the effect on the market is the
same when people move to riskier actions
that makes the market
riskier for everyone.
So if we were to consider all of that,
uh,
if you had say three people
come to you and you had to,
you had to give them some responses
because that's like a mother in law,
people in the family. So you have
to give them some kind of response.
And I might be, feel free to
ask some clarifying questions,
but let's say someone has a
hundred k to invest 1 million,
10 million to invest,
so a hundred k 1 million and 10 million,
they make $100,000 a year that is
going to remain stable and predictable.
It's just assume that on the income
side, uh, they are very cautious.
I think like a lot of people,
the loss aversion and pain of losing
$100 hurts much more than the joy they
derive from making $100.
Uh,
and they have their investible funds,
in this case, a hundred k, 1 million,
10 million in cash or cash equivalence
or some of these safe vehicles currently.
And they say, Howard, I don't know
to do. What are your thoughts?
I think that
one of the most important things of in
investing is to make people comfortable.
It's a mistake to sit there and say,
you should do this.
You should do that regardless
of people's comfort level.
Because if you violate
their comfort level,
if you force him into things that are too
risky for them, and then things go bad,
they're unlikely to do the right thing.
They're more likely to panic
and sell on the way on the lows,
which is the cardinal sin of investing.
Uh,
so it's very important to assess people's
needs and ability to withstand tough
times. Um, clearly, uh, the
person who makes a hundred and,
and,
and has a hundred doesn't have a big
margin of safety for tough times and,
and, and they should invest,
uh, more conservatively.
The person with 10 million, um, uh,
depending on his psychology,
uh,
or her psychology probably would be
willing to stomach some losses in the
pursuit of big gains.
Um,
now people always over
estimate in advance.
They're the equanimity with which
they would greet losses. You know,
back in 1997, eight, nine, when the,
when the stock market and the tech
stocks were rocketing along what a,
what a lot of people I think
said is, well, I, I, you know,
my 401ks been doing so great. I wouldn't
mind if I lost a third of my money.
It's okay. Believe me, when, when,
when they lost a third of their money,
they weren't okay. Uh,
but you know, our mantra,
my mantra for the last few
years has been moved forward,
but with caution and,
and uh,
so in varying degrees to
those three people, uh,
what I would say,
we are investing every day.
We are endeavoring to be fully invested
today other than in funds that are
strictly designated as standby
funds for the, for the crisis.
We are definitely taking risk.
But with caution,
we were cautious firm.
We invest in risky asset classes,
high yield bonds,
distressed debt, uh, real estate, emerging
market stocks and bonds, et Cetera.
These are,
these are risky assets and oak tree
has always taken a low risk approach,
a controlled risk approach to those asset
classes. So when I say with caution,
I mean with more caution than usual.
I think this is a time for
more caution than usual. Uh,
and that's what I would tell those
people, but I don't. So I think that the,
the uh, the, uh,
outlook is not so bad and the prices are
not so high that you have to practice
maximum defensiveness and go to cash and,
and,
and suffer a 1% return on cash.
But I think the outlook is not so
good and prices are not so low,
but this is time for aggressiveness
and I wouldn't be aggressive. The, the,
I think one way to that I help
myself make these decisions,
and it might be helpful to your listeners,
is I constantly remind myself and others
that as an investor there are really
two key risks that we face every day.
Now the first one is obvious and everybody
knows about it's the risk of losing
money. What's the second? Not so
obvious, a little more subtle.
It's the risk of missing
opportunity. And most people, if,
if reminded of the twin risks, they
would say, well, I think that's right.
And the truth is that I don't want to lose
a lot of money. But on the other hand,
I don't want to miss all the
opportunities. So I'm going to compromise,
I'm going to balance the two. I'm going
to do something kind of in the middle. Um,
and that makes sense. Everybody, you know,
other than daredevils and scaredy cats,
everybody should do something in the
middle. Exactly. Where in the middle is,
is debatable and should be a tailored
to their own psyche and financial
position. So the interesting
question is, okay,
what about today?
Today,
should you be at in your normal balance
between the twin risks or should it be
different?
Should you be in a higher risk position
because so many things yields a little
or should you be in a lower risk position?
Because there are so many uncertainties
and I actually think the ladder so fully
invested and being cautious
does not mean being in cash,
but everything you want to do
in the investment business,
there are higher and
lower risk ways to do it.
And I think today is a time
for the lower risk ways.
Uh, I, uh, you know, this is the,
this is not the first time I've
asked a question like this,
but the last time I asked
the first part of that,
which was making a hundred
grand a year, I've, uh,
someone has a hundred grand grand to
spend was actually at the Berkshire
Hathaway shareholder meeting a long,
long time ago. And it was my, my,
my first and only time there and I
was so excited to be there. I mean,
it's Woodstock for investor
nerds and it was, it was,
there was so much excitement. People
were camped out out front to be in line.
I was part of that and I asked someone
working there where the microphone
wireless that was hardest to get to.
And then I sprinted over there and I was
able to ask a Warren and Charlie this
question,
of course,
you know them and the responses
can be very short. And, uh,
I said, if someone, hypothetically,
we're making $100,000 a year,
they had $100,000 to deploy in some way,
how would you suggest
they invest that capital?
And it was along the lines of invest in
the s and p 500 or a low cost index fund
in the SB 500 and get back to work.
And I found that very dissatisfying.
But in retrospect,
uh, certainly not the worst advice
that you could get. Give someone, uh,
how, how do you, uh, what
do you disagree with,
with Warren most on,
what do you guys not see eye to eye on?
You know, Tim, there's a book
out called the Warren Buffet Way,
and I was asked to write the
forward for the latest edition,
and I wrote something called what
Wakes Warren Buffet, Warren Buffet.
And I listed the things that characterize
him extremely high Iq, unemotional,
great analysts understand
what's important,
looks at the things that are important
and figures out their import,
ignores the things that are
unimportant and on and on like that.
And the last one was the most,
one of the most important.
He's not afraid of getting fired.
He doesn't have to worry about the,
the interim consequences
of error most people do.
And, um, so, you know, okay,
so you say your, your advice is, uh,
or his advices invest in an index fund,
fine as far as it goes.
But how much should the person who has
100,000 put the whole hundred thousand in
the stock market, right? And
especially should they do it today?
And if they do it all today,
we're confident the 20 years from now
they're going to have a lot more money and
they're going to be really happy.
What about a year from now? And, and,
uh,
not everybody is financially able to
live through a decline and emotionally
able.
And so as I said,
the first purpose of investing,
especially for people who have
more money than they need to eat,
should be to make you comfortable.
When I started at bank Citibank 50 years
ago, they had a cartoon on the wall.
It said, scared money
never wins. And it's true.
And so everybody should invest
only up to their comfort level.
And, uh, so I, I think I would, I,
I certainly agree with Warren that for
most people they can improve on an index
fund. But, but that's,
and I'm not saying that Warren says that
everybody should put 100% of their net
worth in the index fund, but
clearly they shouldn't. And,
and I was once at a,
uh,
at a talk and I was preceded by a,
by a college professor.
I wounded identify him. Uh,
Warren always says, uh, uh,
praise by name, criticized by
category. So I'll always say,
so I'll say I was, I was
preceded by a college professor.
And here's what he said.
And this guy is known
for pro stocks attitudes.
And he said,
if you are of average risk tolerance,
you should have 85% of your money in this.
No.
If you're a below average risk tolerance,
85 average was Tom's 105.
If you're aggressive,
125% of your net worth should
be in the stock market.
And I just think that most people
can't live in the long run,
in the short run with the consequences
of being that much invested.
Uh, and, and, and, uh, being human.
We are our own worst enemy.
Everything that goes on in the world and
the market conspires to make people buy
when things are going well
and prices are high and sell,
when things are going badly and
prices are low. And, and fighting.
That is the number one theme of the book.
And it's the number one theme of,
of success.
Just from personal experience,
and I mentioned this earlier,
but looking at my response in say 2008,
I had bought a house in 2007 and with some
very unfortunate, uh,
mortgage terms and, uh,
made some very bad decisions also with
money that I had in the stock market at
that time.
And I think in part it was because I,
I couldn't have known how I would
respond under those circumstances.
And when I filled out this very templated
form of course for whoever it was at
the time,
I won't mention any anyone by name,
but it was to what extent would you be
comfortable with a drop in your portfolio
over one quarter or one year,
whatever the,
the form of the question
was and had 10% 20%,
30% and 30% maybe.
I mean pulling it,
the answer out of thin air had to answer
it to get through the online form.
But I'd never experienced
anything similar to that.
And this just came to mind because
I'm looking at it on a book,
at a book on your shelf, uh,
bringing down the house about games.
We were talking about games earlier
as I understand it, Bill Gates,
I think also buffet played
a fair amount of bridge, uh,
certainly many people
in the investing world,
including some people who are
really, really, really fantastic.
Some of the guys from renaissance and so
on poker, uh, then you have backgammon.
What do you play and what do you think
the game that they select says about the
person,
if anything,
and could playing those games help
someone to assess their risk tolerance for
larger types of investing?
Are there other ways to,
in any way accurately determine that?
I think accurately
determine, yes. Quantify. No.
Uh,
but I think that we
can get a handle on our degree
of risk tolerance, risk aversion,
and we should. And, um, you know,
uh,
I was with the, my son and, uh,
one of his friends this week and
his friend is a great chess player.
The interesting thing about people
who play chess is that in chess,
there's no randomness. Uh, you
know, there's no dice to roll.
There's no wind to blow a no
card to pick from the deck. And,
and every,
all the information is on the board
and everybody has all the information.
So it tells you something about
an intellectual process. Um,
and you know,
all the way out to craps,
which where everything's, uh, you know,
in play all the time based on randomness.
Um,
so maybe which game we like, uh,
tells us something about ourselves.
But how we play also tells us
about ourselves. Backgammon,
which is one of my main games,
uh,
which is highly probability intensive.
Um, cause it's all the dies.
It's the dice it and the skill. But
the dice mean a lot. Um, you know, in,
in any situation with any throw of the
dice there are aggressive and defensive
ways to play. So, you know,
probably the interesting thing was if
you played and I watched her for a couple
hours,
I would know if you're aggressive or
defensive or risk averse or risk tolerant
and, and, and you should be able to do
the same for yourself. The one of the,
as I said before, one of the great
things is to understand ourselves. And,
and without that we are really in trouble.
What are some of the things that otherwise
smart people miss about cycles or
misconceptions that they believe to be
true? Like you said with Mark Twain,
that just ain't so, I think the, well,
the,
the biggest mistake you can make is ignore
the repetitive nature of the cyclical
pattern. Uh, Ray Dalio in
his, in his book principles,
uh,
talks about how much analysis
he and his partners did. Uh,
the conclusion of which is the ability
to look at what's going on in the world
or in the market and say,
oh,
that's another one of those life becomes
very easy when you have studied the
past to the extent that you've seen the
recurring patterns and you can recognize
them when they come up again.
So, so, uh, I think that's,
I think that's extremely important.
Um, but the other thing is,
and I think the guiding
quote of the book is a,
is another one from Mark Twain. History
does not repeat, but it does rhyme.
History does not repeat,
the cycles are not ever the
same in terms of amplitude,
speed,
duration,
cause or ramifications.
But they do.
There are themes that repeat that can
help us to identify and properly respond
to cyclical occurrences.
So I say in the book that I,
you know,
I've been in the high yield bond business
now for 40 years and there was a time
when there arose a body of thought
that most defaults a car on bonds,
second anniversary since issuance.
And I don't,
I don't think there's anything
magical about the second anniversary.
And you know,
if people believe that,
then they would sell all the
bonds they had that were 23 years,
23 months old,
and by him back when there were 25
months old if they had survived.
But I don't think they would accomplish
anything by that because they were,
I think they were, they were, uh,
assigning an import to a
number that was not a valid.
So I think it's really important to
recognize cycles and understand them.
I think it's unimportant to assign
importance to these numbers who are rules.
Uh, but it's very important to
understand what's going on around us.
And when, when, when the recovery
is old, the bull market is old,
the psychology is elevated, the, the, uh,
the valuations are high,
then you should know that the odds are
not on your side and you should take some
money off the table and behave in a
more cautious way. And vice versa.
I suppose also on some level necessitates
cultivating a fair degree of patients.
Uh,
I mean it would seem
patients is,
patients is essential.
There was a investment sage named
Peter Bernstein, and he said,
the market is not an
accommodating machine.
He will not give you high returns
because you need or want them.
And you know,
if I believe that right now we're
living in a low return world.
Okay.
And if you say,
Howard,
I need high returns in a low return world,
the only way to try to get them is by
taking a lot of risk. And by definition,
taking a lot of risk is,
is,
is not sure to work and could
have negative consequences.
So I believe that when
you're in a low return world,
you have to accept it and
deal accordingly. Now,
this comes from Joel, which we
started the interview with. Uh,
I talked about Mojo in a memo about 20
years ago. Entitled, it is what it is.
I think one of the most important
things that we can do as adults, be it,
be it in the investment world or the
real world is to say it is what it is.
In other words, accept things for what
they are, deal with them as they are.
Don't spend a lot of time wishing
they were different. Uh, you know,
certainly don't
okay.
Act as if they were different. Uh,
we have to accept the realities.
I've, uh, not that in my,
in my little tiny corner of
investing, which is, I mean,
not even worth mentioning, we late
in this conversation, but I, I,
I only bring it up to tie it to how
helpful actually reading certain,
I'm not going to,
it's not quite scripture,
but Buddhist thinking related to
concepts like Mojo and stoic philosophy,
Epictetus and so on.
Uh,
how helpful that has been to
tempering emotional reactivity.
Uh, you mentioned someone I want to it
to come back to for a second. Uh, Peter,
is it Bernstein or Stein? Ernestine
Bernstein, financial historian. Uh,
sadly passed away. I
think it was in 2009. I,
I've read that you consider him one of
the smartest people you've ever met. Why,
why is that? Are there any other
things that you learned from him?
48 years ago when I was a junior analyst
following xerox for Citibank and I
would give the portfolio managers at the
bank my opinions when I'm came up to me
and said, who is the best analyst on
Wall Street on Xerox? And I said, well,
the one who agrees with me the most is so,
and so.
We always think that the people
who agree us are really smart.
And Peter saw the world the way I did,
but in many cases put it into
words better. Uh, and um,
um, I wrote him a memo, uh,
called risk in o six row
risk revisited in 14.
And then bizarrely one day I
found a memo from him. You pay,
you mentioned he passed
away in o nine. In, in 16,
I found a memo for whom all my desk,
my desk is a little messy and there's a
lot of stuff floating around and it was
a great memo entitled, uh, can
risk be reduced to a number.
And I took a bunch of stuff from that
in a Redo of my memo entitled risk
revisited again. Um, but I just, I
just think that Bernstein is great.
And, and, and in on the subject of risk,
he said every day we
walk into the unknown.
Um, and, and as I said,
you know,
the future is a distribution
of possibilities and some
days we don't even know
what the possibilities are.
And,
and I conclude if I can borrow your
copy of the book, I can include,
uh, with, with a quote from him, uh,
because I think it's so good and,
uh,
if I can find it quickly,
he said the future is not ours to know,
but it helps to know that being
wrong is inevitable and normal,
not some terrible tragedy,
not some awful failing and reasoning.
Not even bad luck in most instances.
Being wrong comes with the franchise of
an activity whose outcome depends on an
unknown future.
And I think that that's a great way to,
to think about the world
we have to work in.
And if you accept and
inhale the unpredictability,
variability and randomness of the world,
I think you're likely to
do a lot better in it. Now,
that doesn't mean you can't invest.
You can invest even boldly.
What it means is you have to assume that
things are not going to always work out
right away. Well, of course they're
not always going to work out,
but they're certainly not always gonna
work out right away, which means what?
You have to have patience. You have
to same power. You have the fortitude,
you have to,
uh,
not invest so much that
if it goes against you,
you're going to panic and get out.
Uh, preparing for an unknown world,
unpredictable,
maybe even hostile world in the short
run is probably a lot smarter than
assuming everything's going to go
right and it's going to go the way you
expected and it's going
to go that way right away.
And you're not going to be tested.
Uh, and, uh, so I, I think that the,
this is the kind of thinking
that, that, that, uh, you know,
when I read Bernstein or, or some of the
other people I've mentioned, you know,
I just go, oh yeah, right, sure.
That, that gets it for me. You know,
and that's why I love his stuff so much.
Uh, Warren Buffet has mentioned how
Fante is of your writing and that,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but if he sees it in his inbox
where he sees one of your letters,
it's one of the first things or the
first thing that he'll pick up to read.
I'd love to ask you about your reading.
Are there any,
say three to five specific newsletters
or columnists or economists or writers
who you find yourself excited to read
these days? Anyone who comes to mind?
I th I think the best, uh, you know,
I worked mainly in the credit area,
not the stock market. So, you know,
most people invest mainly in the stock
market and we've talked a lot about the
stock market. Uh, but that's not
what I do professionally. And, uh,
our oak trees investing is largely in,
in something called credit, which means,
uh, fixed income securities,
bonds and notes and loans, uh,
not issued by governments. That's
the definition of credit. Um,
and in,
in our world,
I think that is a great newsletter
called grant's interest rate observer.
It's a little ironic because it grants
has nothing to do with interest rates are
almost nothing, but it's about credit
and it, and, and in particular,
it exposes a stupidity.
And it exposes companies which seem to
be where people are not bringing enough,
uh,
skepticism and,
and deals that seem unwise
and that kind of thing. And,
and I think they do a great job.
Now it,
I think it's fair to say that it
has a negative cast. In other words,
they're mainly talking
about things which are,
which are rated higher
than they should be,
which you should avoid or bet against.
I don't think they as often talk about
the things that are rated lower than they
should be and present
profit opportunities. But
for credit guys like us,
uh, avoiding the losers is
extremely important. And,
and I think that's a great,
a great newsletter,
not only for the content but for the
attitude and the importance of identifying
misperceptions. You know,
the misperception is the
key to operating in the,
in the markets and the variant perception.
You understand things differently from
the way everybody else understands them
is the key to success.
Assuming you're right, uh,
if you understand everything
just the way everybody else does,
clearly you can outperform.
That's the death knell for would
be a professional investor.
So you have to have, you have to
see things different from others.
That's a necessary condition
for outperformance,
but you also have to see it better than
others. That's necessary to, uh, that the,
the two, the combination of those two is
what I call second level thinking, which,
which I mentioned a couple of times.
You also mentioned how widely read,
uh,
Charlie Munger is and certainly in
poor Charlie's Almanack for instance,
he talks quite a bit about if I'm not
missing Mr roaming a evolutionary biology
and,
and really is able to pull concepts from
seemingly unrelated disciplines into
his sort of power zone of,
of investing. Uh, and, uh,
I've had investors
recommend certain books are,
are much broader than investing,
such as lessons of history
by will and Ariel Durant,
which I found really fascinating also,
I mean, talks about cycles in a way. Uh,
are there any books that
you found recommending a lot
or that you've enjoyed in
the last few years that are
not specific to investing?
Uh, not specific. Yes. My,
my reading is usually closer
in a that then Charlie's a,
so an example, uh, is the book I'm working
on now, which is called fact fullness.
Um, and basically it, it,
it unmasks a lot of misperceptions
that people have about the state of the
world. Uh, and, uh,
they hold these
perceptions, uh, generally,
qualitatively not based on data.
And the author tries to substitute
facts for these perceptions,
Eh,
eh,
he starts with a list of 13 questions
describing the state of the world.
And fascinatingly, uh, the,
I guess he,
it gives you the answer to one and
you have to think about the answer.
The other 12,
the average score on the 12 is too,
and he points out that if you flip
the coin, you'd get six, right?
So the average American gets
two of the 12 questions, right?
And so not only are they
systematically wrong,
but they're wrong in the same direction,
which is they always pick
the more pessimistic answer
when the more optimistic
one is true.
And so he's,
he responds to our bias and he tries
to overcome the ignorance and the bias,
uh, by, by using facts and,
and, and, and some great, uh,
very communicative graphics.
So I would recommend, uh,
impactfulness and I love the
idea of unmasking biases.
You mentioned that, uh, and if I
get this wrong, as I'm restating,
please correct me,
but for in a low yield environment
to get high yield entails increased risk.
Uh,
I know you've written a little bit
about cryptocurrency before. Uh,
the last I saw was about I think, I
think for about a year ago. What is your,
what is your current view or
thoughts on cryptocurrency, if any?
That's one place that people are going,
uh,
often with no understanding of
the technology or anything else.
I mean it scares me enough,
although anyway,
I won't get into my view on that stuff.
But people who are well outside of tech,
well outside of all that getting very,
very bullish as it relates
to cryptocurrency. But
what are your thoughts?
I am what is called a value investor.
And that means you look at the situation,
you don't look at the atmospherics,
you don't look at the aesthetics,
you look at the value,
hard value, uh, the,
the company's assets and the cash flow
that is business producers and you value
those things and you come to something
called the intrinsic value and then you
see if you can buy it for less.
If you pay full intrinsic value,
you'll probably get a fair return.
If you pay more,
you'll probably have an
unsuccessful experience.
But if you can buy it for less
than the intrinsic value, you,
you should have an above average return.
That's value investing.
And I think it is the
intellectually sound,
this form of investing.
And nobody has been able to tell me
the intrinsic value of a bitcoin.
I believe there are assets in this
world where you can come up to intrinsic
value and they are the ones
that produce cashflow companies,
stocks, bonds, buildings,
that kind of thing.
There are a lot of assets in this
world to do not produce cash flow.
You cannot put an intrinsic value on
oil,
gold, diamonds, paintings, bitcoin.
Does it apply to all currencies?
Yes it does. Yes it does. Uh,
we cannot say how many
pounds a dollar is worth.
Um,
we,
we people look at them in terms of
what's called purchasing power parody,
but it doesn't really work very well.
And the truth of the matter is that these
macro considerations to directions of
economies and,
and,
and markets and the currencies and PR,
commodity prices,
I mean, what's the intrinsic
value of an orange, you know, um,
these things I think can't
be predicted reliably.
And in fact the so called macro funds
have been doing quite poorly for years.
Um, so, uh,
there are some things can be
valued in some things a can.
And I believe that bitcoin is one
of the ones that can't be valued.
And everybody says to me,
but you don't understand.
And I wrote about this in
my July 17 memo and, and uh,
and return to it in September, I learned
something between July and September.
That's why I put it in the next memo to,
um,
people said you just don't understand.
People are going to want a currency that
the government can't deflate and that
can't be counterfeited and can't be
stolen and all these things. And um,
so, uh, that's why I returned to it,
but I still don't understand
how it can be valued.
I don't [inaudible] today a bitcoin
is $6,500 here on August the 10th.
And I don't see how you can say it's worth
7,500 or 5,500 or anything like that.
You can say it's going to
be useful in the future.
You can say people want occurrancy
a nongovernmental currency,
but I don't see how you can put
a value on it. And, and uh, uh,
with all of its attractions to the extent
that people find attractions in it.
Last year it went from 1000 to 19,000.
Now, I could be wrong, but that
tells me it's speculative buying.
Uh,
and by the way,
the people who remember what I said
about people who have opinions believe in
their right. Obviously the
people who it traded at 19,000,
somebody thought it was a good buy
at 19,000 cause it was going higher.
And today it's a third of that.
So for the most part,
reasonably valued value investments
do not go up 19 times in a year.
And then down by two thirds.
Are there any understanding that
you are a value investor? Um, you,
you mentioned a few other names and the
bit in the introduction of your book,
Joel Greenblatt, uh,
who I'm also a fan of.
Are there any growth investors,
venture investors who are,
uh, is certainly a person thinks
differently, but are there,
are there any particular growth?
Are Venture investors or people who are
playing a slightly different approach
who you have a lot of respect for
or admire for particular reasons?
Sure.
Let me say,
there are many ways to invest.
There are many people who engage in
activities that I think can't be done.
And there are many people in each one
who do very well. So, you know, I,
I don't,
I don't say mine is the only
way in venture as an example,
and I'm not a futurist, I'm not a dreamer.
I'm not highly risk tolerance. Uh,
I'm not biased to risk
taking. And if, if it,
40 years ago when Citi Bank said to me
they wanted me to start at a high yield
bond portfolio,
if instead they would have said,
I want you to start a venture capital
fund, I probably would have been disaster.
Um, but in the venture
field, you know, the, the,
the firms that success
seems to be recurring,
not random. You know, if, if,
let's say 20%,
10% of venture capital
funds are successful,
you would think that any given firearm,
20% of their funds would be successful.
But there are firms which are
repeatedly successful. Um, you know,
uh,
I was lucky in the last year to get
to meet Bill Gurley of benchmark and,
and, and bill was nice enough to give me
a blurb for the jacket in my book. Uh,
and, and I was very impressed by our
conversation and by, uh, benchmarks,
a record of achievement and
Sequoyah has a great record,
um, and, um, you know,
climate Parkins, et cetera.
Uh, so you can do it. Uh,
but it wouldn't be right for me.
That doesn't mean it's not right for them.
The macro, there are, you know,
I said 15 minutes ago that macro
funds have had pretty bad record.
Some of the greatest investors in
history have been macro investors. Uh,
George Soros and Stan
Druckenmiller, for example, uh,
have been fabulous. They, they, they
probably have the highest returns of,
of everybody, um, and
quantitative investing,
renaissance and so forth. So, uh, again,
it would be a terrible form
of Hubris to say, my aunt,
my way is the only way my way's the
way we're way that works for me.
And by the way,
if you look at the others,
the success ratio is not terribly high.
Uh,
but certainly there are
people who've done it. Great.
Yeah, there's a very high concentration
of success and a handful at least within
venture. Uh, yeah.
Bill's a very smart guy.
And all the firms you mentioned
have done really, really well. Uh,
so I, I've heard said, ah, this is not,
not from, not from you in these words,
I don't think, but that, you know,
the right decision at the wrong
time is the wrong decision. And, uh,
I'm,
I'm very excited about the new book
and the literacy of cycles that you are
helping people to do develop
with this. Uh, and, uh,
we're gonna wrap up in
just a few questions. Um,
are there any particular,
uh,
mental models or heuristics that are in
this book or that you've used in your
investing life do you think
are particularly valuable
kind of across the board
in life? I know it's a big
question and you probably have, uh,
quite a few different directions
you could go with that.
But just in terms of
becoming a clearer thinker,
a better operating human being,
does this,
does anything come to mind that we haven't
discussed so far as it relates to any
type of mental model that
would be worth mentioning?
We wrap up.
Well, you know, Tim,
when I finished writing the book
and I was thinking about cycles,
I said to myself, so for example,
the economy grows about two,
two and a half percent a year on average.
Why doesn't it just grow two and
a half percent year every year?
Why is it sometimes four and sometimes
one and sometimes five and sometimes
negative.
And the answer is accesses
and their correction.
And people get too excited and they
overexpand their businesses or they invest
too much or they invest too much using
debt and then something goes wrong and,
and that,
and their accesses are produced
booms and then something goes wrong.
And those excessive activities
turned out to be unsustainable.
And they are then corrected by selling
off inventory, closing plants or,
or liquidating leverage portfolio
and those produce busts.
So accesses and their correction.
And I think the best thing that people
can do is be on the lookout for those
things. And when other people are
engaging in accesses to the upside,
we should turn cautious.
And when other people are over
correcting to the downside,
we should turn aggressive. And,
uh, and, and I think, you know,
it's been a big part of what Bruce and
I have accomplished for the oak tree
investors and my other
partners and colleagues to,
uh, and, and it's something
that everybody can do if they,
um,
if they turn their mind to it.
Well, Howard, I really appreciate
the time today. Good. This is,
this is,
this is very fun for me and hopefully,
and I believe will be valuable for people
listening just to mention a few things.
Of course people can find mastering
the market cycle, subtitle,
getting the odds on your side,
everywhere books are sold. Uh,
you can also learn more
at mastering the market.
cycle.com people can learn more about
oak tree@oaktreecapital.com and on social
media you have Twitter, Facebook, and
Linkedin, all the same Howard marks book.
Is there anything else that you would
like to say to the people listening and he
recommendation question,
they should ponder action.
You might ask them to take
anything at all. Uh, besides, uh,
besides the book itself,
which I encourage people to check out.
Well, first of all, we've made
repeated reference to my memos.
They're all available
online@oaktreecapital.com, uh,
under the heading of
insights chairman's memos.
You can get the last 29 years worth.
You can also sign up for a service that
will notify you when one is published.
The price is right because they're
free. Uh, and, and I hope people will,
will read them.
And then I just want to say that I like
to hear from people so I don't always
have time to answer everybody,
but my of the memos
and the books has been enormously
rewarding because I get lovely memos from
people would say, uh, that I
made a complex things seem clear.
Um, that's the one that
gets me going the most.
So if people want to comment or
if they want to take issue or,
or ask a question,
I'll try to get back to them.
And this is the best way to reach out,
to send you a note on social media or a,
I would advise against giving out any
type of email address that will get
delusion,
but um,
or maybe the answer is they should figure
it out while we're on social media and
we'd be glad to hear
from there. Perfect. Uh,
why are to thank you again so much for
the time and for everybody listening
links to everything we discussed will
be in the show notes as usual@tim.blog
forward slash, podcast. And until
next time. Thank you for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one, this is five
bullet Friday. Do you
want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up, I hope you enjoy it. This
episode is brought to you by helix sleep.
Last year I focused on dramatically
improving a few things. Surprise,
surprise most.
It'll be the quality of my sleep,
which seems to affect just
about everything. This led
me to revisit, you name it,
my daily routine, morning
routine, exercise, diet,
all the way to what I slept on and I
ended up getting all new beds here in
Austin, Texas, including
mattresses from Helix sleep.
He looks as built a slip quiz that takes
two minutes to complete and they use
the answers to match your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress. Whether you're a side
sleeper, hot sleeper, cold sleeper.
Are you like flush?
You like firm with Helix,
there's no more guessing or confusion.
Just go to sleep.com forward slash Tim
take their two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life.
That is their promise for couples.
It looks can even split the
mattress down in the middle,
providing individual support needs
and feel preferences for each side.
They have a 10 year warranty and you can
test drive your mattress for 100 nights.
Risk free.
Right now he looks is offering up to $125
off of all mattress orders to check it
out.
Get up to 125 off at Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim that's helix
sleep.com forward slash 10 or $125 off
your mattress order.
Take a look.
He looks asleep.com/tim this
episode is brought to you by inc.
Tell used them personally. Ever since
I wrote the four hour work week,
I've been asked over and over again
how I choose to delegate tasks,
how I do 80 20 analysis and so on.
At the root of many of those decisions
is a simple question or actually two
questions.
Number one,
how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life and use that in investing
as well?
The second,
how can I spend a little money or moderate
money to save significant time inc
tell is one of those investments.
They're a turnkey solution for all of
your imaginable customer care units.
I used hotel during the launch of
the four hour body which was very,
very involved and they provided 24
seven customer service for my land rush
campaign because it was critical for
me to take care of every person who
purchased my books and participate in
this allowed me to focus on the things
that I am better at,
my strengths like marketing claim
that we'd worked on for six months
implementing that and until trains their
experience customer service reps to
know your business and your products
inside and out and make your customers
raving fans.
They answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they
can do so across all platforms.
Giving email, phone, social media,
texts in chat,
leaving your customers with Horst Service,
or just mediocre service,
which by the way,
in a competitive pool is a huge liability.
Long wait times are unanswered messages
carries a massive cost and risk to your
business. Intel removes the logistics
headaches of this type of communication,
allowing you to focus on your
strengths and grow your business.
It can be a real competitive advantage.
And I see many,
many ecommerce companies
and tech companies thinking
of customer service as a
good enough checkbox for an afterthought.
And it just like airbnb
design and innovative ways
to be a competitor and to win
that you can do.
Same thing with customer service.
So as a listener of this podcast,
you can get up to
$10,000 off the discount,
$10,000 off your startup fees and costs
by visiting [inaudible] dot com forward
slash 10 so check it out.
More Info,
go to [inaudible] Dot com I N
K t e l.com forward slash 10.